las mujeres son más propensas que los hombres al alzhéimer.
El alzhéimer es la causa más común
de demencia en el planeta,
y afecta a cerca de 6 millones de personas solo en EE. UU.
Pero casi dos tercios de todas esas personas,
en realidad, son mujeres.
Por cada hombre que sufre alzhéimer
hay dos mujeres.
¿Por qué es eso en todo el mundo?
¿Es la edad?
¿Es la esperanza de vida?
¿Qué más podría ser?
Hace un par de años,
lancé la Women's Brain Initiative
en el Weill Cornell Medicine en Nueva York,
para responder a estas preguntas.
Y esta noche, estoy aquí con algunas respuestas.
Resulta que nuestros cerebros envejecen de forma diferente,
y la menopausia juega en esto un papel fundamental para las mujeres.
La mayoría de gente piensa en el cerebro como una caja negra,
aislada del resto del cuerpo.
Pero en realidad, nuestros cerebros están en constante interacción
con el resto de nosotros.
Y quizás sorprendentemente,
las interacciones con el sistema reproductivo
son cruciales para el envejecimiento del cerebro en las mujeres.
Estas interacciones están mediadas por nuestras hormonas.
Y sabemos que las hormonas difieren entre sexos.
Los hombres tienen más testosterona, las mujeres tienen más estrógenos.
Pero lo que importa aquí
es que esas hormonas difieren en su longevidad.
La testosterona masculina no se agota hasta el final de la vida,
lo que es un proceso lento y prácticamente sin síntomas, por supuesto.
(Risas)
Los estrógenos femeninos, por otra parte,
comienzan a desaparecer durante la mediana edad, la menopausia,
que es cualquier cosa menos asintomática.
Asociamos la menopausia con los ovarios,
pero cuando las mujeres dicen que tienen sofocos,
sudores nocturnos, insomnio, lapsus de memoria, depresión, ansiedad,
estos síntomas no empiezan en los ovarios.
Empiezan en el cerebro.
Estos son síntomas neurológicos.
Pero no estamos acostumbrados a pensar en ellos como tales.
Entonces, ¿por qué es eso?
¿Por qué nuestros cerebros se ven afectados por la menopausia?
Pues, ante todo,
nuestros cerebros y ovarios son parte de nuestro sistema neuroendocrino.
Como parte del sistema,
el cerebro habla con los ovarios
y los ovarios responden al cerebro,
cada día en nuestras vidas como mujeres.
La salud de los ovarios está conectada con la salud del cerebro.
Y a la inversa.
Al mismo tiempo,
las hormonas como los estrógenos no solo participan en la reproducción,
sino también en la función cerebral.
Y el estrógeno en particular, o estradiol,
es realmente clave para la producción de energía en el cerebro.
A nivel celular,
el estrógeno literalmente empuja a las neuronas
a quemar glucosa para crear energía.
Si su estrógeno es alto,
la energía de su cerebro es alta.
Sin embargo, cuando el estrógeno disminuye
sus neuronas comienzan a disminuir y envejecen más rápido.
Y estudios han demostrado que este proceso
puede incluso llevar a la formación de placas amiloides,
o placas de alzhéimer,
que son un sello distintivo de la enfermedad de alzhéimer.
Estos efectos son más fuertes en regiones específicas del cerebro
comenzando con el hipotálamo,
que se encarga de regular la temperatura corporal.
Cuando el estrógeno no activa el hipotálamo correctamente,
el cerebro no puede regular correctamente la temperatura del cuerpo.
Esos sofocos que tienen las mujeres,
ese es el hipotálamo.
Luego está el tronco encefálico a cargo del dormir y despertar.
Cuando los estrógenos no activan
bien el tronco encefálico,
tenemos problemas para dormir.
O es la amígdala,
el centro emocional del cerebro; cerca del hipocampo,
el centro de memoria del cerebro.
Cuando los niveles de estrógeno disminuyen en estas regiones,
tal vez empezamos a tener cambios de humor
y a olvidar cosas.
Esta es la anatomía cerebral de la menopausia, por así decirlo.
Pero permítanme mostrarles
cómo se puede ver el cerebro de una mujer real.
Este es un tipo de escáner cerebral
llamada tomografía por emisión de positrones o TEP.
Se ve en los niveles de energía del cerebro.
Y así es como quieren que se vea el cerebro
cuando tengan 40 años.
Realmente bien y brillante.
Este cerebro pertenece a una mujer de 43 años
cuando se la escaneó por primera vez, antes de la menopausia.
Y este es el mismo cerebro solo ocho años después,
tras la menopausia.
si los ponemos uno al lado del otro,
creo que pueden ver fácilmente cómo el amarillo brillante
se vuelve naranja, casi púrpura.
Es una caída del 30 % de los niveles de energía cerebral.
Ahora en general,
esto no parece sucederle a un hombre de la misma edad.
En nuestros estudios con cientos de personas,
mostramos que los hombres de mediana edad suelen tener
niveles de energía cerebral altos.
Para las mujeres, la energía cerebral suele estar bien antes de la menopausia,
pero disminuye gradualmente durante la transición.
Y esto se encontró independientemente de la edad.
No importaba si las mujeres tenían 40, 50 o 60 años.
Lo que más importaba era que estaban en el climaterio.
Por supuesto necesitamos más investigación para confirmarlo,
pero parece que el cerebro femenino en la mediana edad
es más sensible al envejecimiento hormonal
que simplemente al envejecimiento cronológico.
Es una información importante con la que contar
porque muchas mujeres pueden sentir estos cambios.
Muchas de nuestras pacientes me han dicho
que sienten que sus mentes las están engañando,
por decirlo suavemente.
Realmente quiero validar esto, porque es real.
Y solo para aclarar, si es su caso,
Ud. no está loca.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Es importante.
Muchas mujeres se han preocupado de estar perdiendo la cabeza.
Pero la verdad es que el cerebro podría estar en una transición
o estar en medio una transición
y necesita tiempo y apoyo para ajustarse.
Además, si alguien está preocupado
de que las mujeres de mediana edad podrían tener un bajo rendimiento,
agregaré rápidamente que observamos el rendimiento cognitivo,
Dios no lo quiera, ¿verdad?
(Risas)
Que no sea así.
Pero al observar el rendimiento cognitivo,
no encontramos ninguna diferencia entre hombres y mujeres
antes y después de la menopausia.
Y otros estudios también lo confirman.
Básicamente, podemos estar cansadas,
pero somos igual de agudas.
(Risas)
Pongan eso a un lado.
Dicho todo esto,
hay algo más mucho más serio que merece nuestra atención.
Si recuerdan,
mencioné que la disminución de los estrógenos podría fomentar
la formación de placas amiloides o placas de alzhéimer.
Pero hay otro tipo de escáner cerebral que examina estas placas.
Y lo usamos para mostrar que los hombres de mediana edad no tienen ninguna
lo cual es genial.
Pero para las mujeres,
hay un aumento considerable durante la transición a la menopausia.
Y quiero ser muy, muy clara aquí,
es que no todas las mujeres desarrollan las placas,
y no todas las mujeres con placas desarrollan demencia.
Tener placas es un factor de riesgo,
de ninguna manera es un diagnóstico, especialmente en esta etapa.
Pero aun así, es una buena idea
asociar el alzhéimer con la menopausia.
Pensamos en la menopausia como algo de la mediana edad
y el alzhéimer como algo de la vejez.
Pero en realidad,
muchos estudios, incluido el mío propio,
demostraron que el alzhéimer comienza con cambios negativos en el cerebro
años, si no décadas, antes de los síntomas clínicos.
Para las mujeres,
parece que este proceso empieza en la mediana edad,
durante la menopausia.
Lo que es una información muy importante
porque nos da una línea de tiempo para empezar a buscar esos cambios.
En términos de línea de tiempo,
la mayoría de mujeres pasan por la menopausia en sus 50 años.
Pero puede ser más temprano,
a menudo debido a intervenciones médicas.
Y el ejemplo común es una histerectomía u ooforectomía,
que es la extirpación quirúrgica del útero
o de los ovarios.
Y por desgracia, hay una evidencia
de que tener el útero, y, más aún, los ovarios extirpados
antes de la menopausia
se correlaciona con un mayor riesgo de demencia en mujeres.
Y sé que esto es una noticia perturbadora,
y definitivamente es una noticia deprimente,
pero necesitamos hablar de ello
porque la mayoría de las mujeres no son conscientes de la correlación,
y es una información muy importante que se debe tener.
Además, nadie sugiere que las mujeres rechacen estos procedimientos
si los necesitan.
El punto aquí es que necesitamos entender mejor
qué ocurre en nuestros cerebros, mientras avanzamos en la menopausia,
natural o médica,
y cómo proteger nuestros cerebros en el proceso.
Entonces, ¿cómo hacemos eso?
¿Cómo protegemos nuestros cerebros?
¿Deberíamos tomar hormonas?
Es una pregunta justa, es una buena pregunta.
Y la respuesta más corta posible en este momento
es que la terapia hormonal puede ser de ayuda
para aliviar una serie de síntomas, como sofocos,
pero actualmente no se recomienda para la prevención de la demencia.
Y muchos estamos trabajando en probar diferentes fórmulas,
diferentes dosis y diferentes plazos,
y con suerte, todo este trabajo conducirá a un cambio
en recomendaciones en el futuro.
Mientras tanto, hay otras cosas que podemos hacer hoy
para apoyar a nuestras hormonas y sus efectos en el cerebro
que no requieren medicamentos,
pero requieren echar un vistazo a nuestro estilo de vida.
Eso es por la comida que comemos,
cuánto ejercicio hacemos,
cuánto dormimos o no dormimos,
cuánto estrés tenemos en nuestras vidas,
son todas las cosas que pueden tener impacto en nuestras hormonas,
para mejor o para peor.
La comida, por ejemplo.
Hay muchas dietas ahí fuera,
pero los estudios han mostrado que la dieta mediterránea en particular
es favorable para la salud de las mujeres.
Las mujeres con esta dieta tienen un riesgo mucho menor
de deterioro cognitivo, depresión,
enfermedad cardíaca, embolia y cáncer,
y también tienen menos sofocos.
Lo interesante de esta dieta
es que es bastante rica en comidas que contienen estrógenos
en forma de fitoestrógenos o estrógenos de plantas
que actúan como estrógenos suaves en nuestros cuerpos.
Algunos fitoestrógenos se relacionan con un posible riesgo de cáncer,
pero no los de esta dieta, que son seguros.
En especial las semillas de lino,
semillas de sésamo, albaricoques secos,
legumbres y varias frutas.
Y buenas noticias,
el chocolate negro contiene fitoestrógenos también.
La dieta es una forma de ganar estrógenos,
pero es tan importante como evadir cosas que suprimen nuestros estrógenos,
especialmente el estrés.
El estrés puede literalmente robarnos los estrógenos,
y es porque el cortisol, que es la principal hormona del estrés,
trabaja en equilibrio con nuestros estrógenos.
Así que, si el cortisol sube, nuestros estrógenos bajan.
Si el cortisol disminuye, nuestros estrógenos vuelven a subir.
Reducir el estrés es muy importante.
No solo ayuda a su día,
también ayuda a su cerebro.
Estas son solo algunas cosas
que podemos hacer para apoyar a nuestros cerebros, y hay más.
Pero lo importante aquí
es que cambiar la forma en que entendemos el cerebro femenino
realmente cambia la forma en la que lo cuidamos,
y la forma en que enmarcamos la salud de las mujeres.
Y cuantas más mujeres demanden esta información
antes podremos romper los tabúes en torno a la menopausia,
y también encontrar las soluciones que realmente funcionen,
no solo para el alzhéimer,
sino para la salud cerebral de las mujeres en conjunto.
La salud del cerebro es la salud de la mujer.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Oh, gracias.